in this video we'll be explaining every
Loki variant we know about in the MCU so
here are 10 different variants of Loki
as seen in the Disney plus series the
first Loki variant we're going to talk
about is the one we're most familiar
with the Loki from the sacred timeline
of the MCU this is the Loki that we
followed since his debut in Thor where
he was revealed to be the adopted son of
Odin and the brother of Thor this Loki
has gone through a lot of changes
throughout his appearances in the MCU
from being a villain in The Avengers to
an anti-hero and Thor the Dark World and
Thor Ragnarok to a tragic victim in
Avengers Infinity War where he was
killed by Thanos this low-key variant
story seemed to be over until Loki l1130
the one that the Loki series focuses on
also known as variant l1130 by the time
variance Authority or the TVA this Loki
was created during the events of
Avengers end game when the Avengers went
back in time to steal the Infinity
Stones from before their destruction by
Thanos during their mission they
encountered the Loki from 2012 who had
just been captured by The Avengers after
his failed invasion of New York this
Loki managed to escape with the
Tesseract creating a branch in the
timeline that deviated from the sacred
timeline this Loki was then captured by
the TVA an organization that monitors
and maintains the order of the Sacred
timeline and was recruited by agent
Mobius to help him hunt down another
Loki variant that was causing chaos
across timelines this Loki's Journey led
him to discover many secrets about the
TVA the sacred timeline in himself as
well as to meet other Loki variants
along the way one of the most memorable
Loki variants we saw in the Loki series
was classic Loki played by guest actor
Richard E Grant he was seen sporting the
classic Loki costume dating back to the
first appearance of Loki in the Marvel
comic journey into mystery number 85
issued in 1952. classic look he thinks
himself to be a coward in this
adaptation since he didn't face Thanos
which led to the death of the original
Loki in the MCU eventually he grew
lonely and started missing his brother
Thor but as he tried to leave the planet
to go back to Asgard he was captured by
the TVA classic Loki sacrificed himself
to help Loki l-1130 and Sylvie escape
from eliaith a monstrous Cloud that
devours everything in its path by
creating a massive illusion of Asgard
demons trading his immense power and
potential another Loki variant we met in
the Loki series was kid Loki played by
Jack veal he was the ruler of the void a
desolate place at the end of time where
the TVA dumps everything they prune from
the timelines kid Loki claimed that he
killed Thor in his timeline which was
his Nexus event that caused him to be
captured by the TVA kid Loki was
accompanied by alligator Loki another
Loki variant we'll talk about later he
gave Loki l-1130 a sword made from one
of the horns of his helmet and helped
him and Sylvia escape from the void
osvaloki was another Loki variant we
encountered in the Loki Series played by
dalbia oporai he was one of the Loki's
that lived in the void along with kid
Loki classic Loki and alligator Loki
bospholoki claimed that he had wielded
all six Infinity Stones in his timeline
which was his Nexus event that caused
him to be captured by the TVA however
his claim was dubious and he had no
proof to back it up osfoloki betrayed
his fellow lokies by awang with
President Loki another low-key variant
that we'll talk about later but was
double crossed by him and his followers
oshville looky fought against the other
lookies in a chaotic brawl and his
ultimate fate is still unknown Sylvia is
the female variant of Loki that Mobius
and the other TVA agents were hunting in
the Loki Series played by Sofia
dimartino she was taken by the TBA as a
child while playing in Asgard but it's
still unknown why she was taken or what
her Nexus event was that led to her
capture Sylvie managed to escape from
the TVA and begin request to uproot it
and Destroy everyone in charge of it she
used her power of Enchantment to possess
and manipulate people across the
timelines and to hide in apocalyptic
events where her actions wouldn't create
any branches in the timeline she also
planted time bombs in various locations
creating multiple branches that
overwhelmed the TBA she eventually met
Loki l-1130 and formed an uneasy
alliance with him to find the truth
behind the TVA and the sacred timeline
she also developed a romantic bond with
him which created a unique Nexus event
that alerted the TV8 to their location
Sylvie was the one who killed he who
remains the creator of the TVA and The
Keeper of the Sacred timeline unleashing
a multiversal war alligator Loki was one
of the most surprising and hilarious
Loki variants we saw on the Loki series
he was an alligator with Loki's helmet
and he was apparently a Loki variant
that had been captured by the TVA along
with him we also saw thrag a variant of
Thor in the form of a frog Gator Loki
was loyal to kid Loki and he even bit
off the hand of President Loki when he
tried to take over the void he also
helped Loki l-1130 and Sylvia escaped
from the void and was last seen with kid
Loki and classic Loki president Loki was
another Loki variant we saw in the Loki
Series played by Tom Hiddleston himself
he was based on the comic book storyline
where Loki ran for president of the
United States in 2162. he was the leader
of a group of Loki's that followed him
to the void where he tried to take over
the kingdom of kid Loki however he was
betrayed by bosfoloki who had made a
deal with him and then by his own
followers who turned on him for a better
offer he was attacked by alligator Loki
who bit off his hand and then by the
other lookies who started a massive
fight among themselves Frost giant Loki
was a variant that we briefly saw in the
Loki series during a montage of
different Loki's being processed by the
TVA he was a blue-skinned red-eyed
horned giant resembling the frost
drawings of yotenheim the race that Loki
originally belonged to before he was
adopted by Odin it's unknown what his
Nexus event was or what happened to him
after he was captured by the TVA Tour de
France Loki was another Loki variant
that we briefly saw in the Loki series
during the same Montage of different
Loki's being processed by the TVA he was
a cyclist wearing a yellow Jersey and
implying that he had won the Tour to
France the most famous bicycle race in
the world it's unknown what his Nexus
event was or what happened to him after
he was captured by the TVA subscribe for
more Marvel content and if you liked the
video check out the one on your screen
too